I'm curious on how you go about casting
for your films you know because you
hand-picked angel you know he didn't he
didn't audition for you just kind of
said you don't have putting in a movie
this is that is that the standard thing
where you kind of right with people in
mind and then cast them have you gone
through the audition process I don't
write with anybody or mine I I write the
story first the story tells me at what
the characters going to be I don't
because I think if I predetermined it
for someone else and then that didn't
work out and now you know the character
doesn't hold the same weight because you
wrote it for a person not for the
character to live on its own so i write
the characters to live and breathe on
their own I don't think about any one
person in mind and then I you know
hopefully I've written enough detailed
the character enough to wear almost like
when I see the person and the person
performs and I'm like there you are and
I'm just like dear you're the guy like I
already know who my detective Morgan is
I saw your detective Morgan any guys
like what in the lead for the for the
trailer I knew my lead bad guy the
moment he got out the car just like up
you're the lead and uses I got act you
know that off to look and I said it's an
energy thing for me and it's just how
people exhumed energy and it's just like
okay you you you exude the essence of
this character now all I need you to do
is protect them you know and then that's
my job is to help them project that
character you know but I think it all
comes from a source feeling that I get
from people when I meet them you know
I've got to feel some type of energy
something from the character within them
and then we help you know bring that out
and let you know help them express it
you know but uh yeah I don't definitely
don't write for a specific person
because i think that would you know kind
of limit the character because you'd end
up limiting limiting the character to
the person's abilities that you're
writing for as opposed to letting the
character just be so I'd rather just
right for the character and then find
the actor who can you know meet the part
and luckily angel has been meeting every
part so far good I mean for for a person
who
taking an acting class he steps up and
I'll give you a classic example look at
the end of the wait now at the end of
redemption now mind you this is angel
and I going for two days that last take
when he chokes me out on the ground and
then he goes picks up the laptop and
leaves the room that was tape number 18
here I was we were exhausted and this
was ok angel this is the last taken a
whole short is going to be one through a
shot so we're coming from a full-on
fight sequence to a point where he
chokes me out and now he's got to get up
and act at the end of this and now do
something after he's got to pick up the
laptop and I say I when you pick up the
laptop I want you to turn around and
look at me but that look I want you to
give it's got to say that number one you
regret what you did number two you're
willing to still go on and stay the
course because what you're doing is
right you know and I was the third the
third was like something engaging that
you know you had a connection that you
know I wanted to feel that the audience
to feel that I was somebody to you
without you saying it you know that I
meant something to you without you
having to actually say the words and I
have to take 18 and I tell them this and
like take 17 there's a little i
literally would finish to take you're
gonna give me this isn't a look and we
got to get it now because we're losing
the light it were tired and he nailed it
and when I saw that and I was just like
that's an actor and I told you after to
it just like as you gave it two in one
look no words one look and it's just
like a net that's when I was just like
okay angels the real deal and he can do
it cuz I I don't know if I could do that
man it was just like you give it all in
one look man it's just like he has a he
has a way of being macho but then have a
vulnerability that he can and show you
at the same time and that's what I want
to you know present that's what I really
dig with him as an annual in there right
now you know he could really do both and
actually really like
and then as an actor so it's cool
you